[Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  hello  this is one of the most tragic  incidents that happened in our armed  forces  okay  the aircraft is in tip-top shape  it's not brand new but it's in a very  good condition as a matter of fact  when the incident trans when it was  delivered to the armed forces of the  philippines  it has more than 11 000  flying hours remaining and when accident  this accident happened it still has  around  11 000 flying hours remaining before  the next maintenance of this aircraft  accidents like this that needed  investigation  may have to other aspects to look into  we look at facility  equipment weather  skills of the pilot all this will have  to be taken into consideration